but so i bring this up too because i'm
i'm just curious as to
the way uh
i'm i have people who make asian jokes
you know at me throughout my whole life
and i think they're hilarious yeah i
mean because i know my friends are just
like ribbon on me
or uh the you know they're just
making fun of the stereotypes and the
absurdity it doesn't affect me because
i'm secure in who i am and i'm just like
oh that's a funny funny thing like if
there's a stereotype about asian people
and then i end up doing something and
then people point it out i'll be like ah
geez you know it's like it's fun
i'm not i'm only a quarter korean uh
part japanese and korean but i'm curious
as to like what would your approach be
in circumstances where someone might be
like someone made a racist joke i'm
upset about it i don't know
honestly that's my honest question it
really depends on the context and
situational details
um i do think it's interesting that they
just took down the first episode of the
office
which is it was the first episode i
think so no fact check me on that okay
uh the old ones yeah yeah which i saw
coming yeah i saw it coming and it was i
unfortunately no one asked for this but
um here we are here we are
so is it the first one
i'm i'm not pulling up snopes on this no
way
all right so here we have it from metro
office the uh the office u.s fans
furious as comedy central removes
diversity day episode from schedule are
you a big fan of the office yeah
especially in that episode especially
that episode that is one of the most
brilliant episodes of the office
so they say diversity day is the second
installment of the first season second
installment
of the office u.s and follows michael as
he forces the staff at dunder mifflin to
undergo a racial diversity seminar a
consultant larry wilmore arrives to each
staff about tolerance and diversity but
michael insists on imparting his own
knowledge aggravating both the
consultant and the entire office staff
and creates his own diversity seminar he
eventually assigns each staff member in
an index card with a different race on
it causing tempers to slowly simmer
until they finally snap so what do they
say comedy central
is removing diversity episode from the
rotation is so corporate and stupid
why why was it removed though they said
they say it was taken down they don't
really explain exactly why it was taken
down or was their official statement or
anything just as video unavailable
wow
did you did you hear like why it was
removed or what the reason was they say
from time to time they'll they'll not
play certain episodes in rotation from
time to time i mean i
don't take a brain surgery to figure out
why this is listen maybe maybe there's
something we don't know we can give them
the benefit of the doubt but i
i suspect it is the reason that we think
it is
that is a funny episode
it's such a great episode it's because
no no it's tough to say because like
when it comes to comedy if you're making
someone the butt of the joke that in
general is kind of kind of hard for me
to swallow i get i get kind of like why
would you hurt that michael scott that's
the michael scott is a ridiculous human
being that's the whole point you see an
idiot making mistakes yeah that's the
point of that and you you also learn to
love you you you learn to to fall in
love with that idiot
that's the whole point if you take see
this is why i ultimately think so so
much that's happening with regards to
critical race theory
uh broadly speaking is going to lead to
the death not well hopefully not the
death but
a suppression of art and the arts and
absolutely we as theory of enchantment
use the arts to teach everything so like
if you if you enroll in our online
course
we use
uh philosophy and music and poetry and
film to actually teach people our three
main principles because we know that the
purpose of the arts is to remind people
of the complexity of the human
experience as opposed to my opinion
politics these days which reduces and
stereotypes and caricatures human beings
to one label or the other the entire
purpose of the arts is to be expansive
and so i'm not surprised if in fact this
is the reason why that happened with the
office
i'm not surprised because that is the
inevitable
that's the logical conclusion and what's
ultimately
ironic about this is that that means
that a lot of things that are coming out
of critical race theory or critical race
theory light or whatever you want to
call it are ultimately antithetical to
the african-american ethos and that is
one of the greatest
scandals that no one is talking about
what do you mean the african-american
ethos what is that like so there's a
great author albert murray who wrote
this book of the omni americans or
alternatives to the folklore of white
supremacy he wrote it in like the 70s or
something like that he was this really
dope jazz critic
and he talked about how within
african-american culture
there is
what he calls a kind of idiomatic
expression
which he defines as impromptu heroism
culture another synonym of this is the
hero's journey so if you're familiar
with like joseph campbell or carl jung
and that sort of thing and he talks
about how in jazz
as an art form and in
the blues there's this
philosophy that affords musicians the
ability not only to literally play with
music but metaphorically play with
anything that life brings them both the
both the negative potential and the
positive potential and that is a part of
the artistic art form that is central to
african american culture and so once you
start
once you start going down the path of
the death of metaphor the death of
context
and all these things you're talking
about the death of art and you're
talking about something the death of
something very central to african
american life i love this about jazz is
because you'll start on a note you're in
a key and you'll hit all the wrong notes
that aren't in the right key yeah then
you'll you'll end on the right note in
the key and that's like the hero's
journey all the mistakes along the way
and then you're which are necessary
which are necessary there's this uh
recording i was listening to recently of
norm mcdonald okay he was on a radio
show apparently with like a woke
like producer or radio host or maybe
she's just one of those people who's
like i'm just going to say what i'm
supposed to say i'm on the radar
canceled and nor macdonald have you ever
listened to this guy
i don't think so i mean i know of him
but i know he i don't think i've heard
him definitely he's got this thing where
he talks in a very like slow and blunt
way and that's how he drives his comedy
so he's talking and he goes
you two might get mad at me but i'm
quoting norma mcdonald and this is oh no
is this one of these no no no he says
he says black people are poorer than
white people and poor people are
dangerous and he was just he was quoting
information right that's what he says
and then the host goes no oh whoa whoa
you you can't say that no no and he was
like what do you mean and she's like you
you can't say that about black people
and he goes you think black people are
richer than white people
no no i'm not saying that and he goes
poor people commit crimes that's what
they keep saying isn't it he's like i
don't think i think systemic racism is a
real thing and that means you and and so
the way he said it yeah shocked and
offended people they started getting
calls and people were calling in like
you can't say that you know i went to
school with two black people and they
were they were way richer than i was and
then he goes yeah and a guy in a
wheelchair could probably be faster than
me but if i said i'm typically faster
than people in wheelchairs i'd be
telling you the truth yeah and so what
was really what i found really
fascinating about
what he said when he said that is we
often hear from the critical race
theorists things like um systemic racism
is a real problem which creates
generational wealth gaps which results
in a disproportionate amount of black
people being impoverished relative to
white people
however there are more white people who
are impoverished then they say poverty
breeds crime and
actually i'm my understanding is it's
all true right your crime isn't based on
race it's based on
poverty levels circumstances but when
nor mcdonald just says it that way yeah
it actually made them argue against him
because the way he said it was so blunt
it came off as kind of offensive or
racist you know what i mean yeah yeah i
don't know i i was curious about it when
you had mentioned something before
before i got the jazz thing came and
kind of threw me off track that's what
jazz does that's right that's right
you'll be back though
in talking about like
um
you're making a comment about diversity
trainings and like critical race theory
and it's like removing
art the arts fundamentally that is my
biggest issue
with it i guess the reason i want to
bring this mcdonald's thing is that i
think it shows
the
there's something about the way you say
things
it's less to do with what the idea is
for a lot of these people who are
claiming to be like anti-racist or
whatever that the way nor macdonald
could come out and say this but then the
people
so you think if he would have said it
differently it wouldn't have offended
people
absolutely i think if norma mcdonald
said you know one of the challenges we
face is systemic racism which has
resulted in a disproportionate amount of
the black community being impoverished
and then you find that racists blame
them when the poverty leads to crime and
people say oh yes i i agree with that
that's very very intelligent but when
norm mcdonald the regular guy is like
says what he said they're like whoa whoa
you can't say that and all of a sudden
like their own idea brought back to them
like in from a mirror of a regular guy
is all of a sudden that without but in a
different form
and just is he intentionally offensive
does he aim does he try to offend people
well yes but in this capacity i think
it's just who he is okay it's like he's
he's the kind of guy who's just gonna
whittle it down very basically and then
he had he was kind of shocked that they
were like
you can't say that no he was like what
do you mean he's like
we say it all the time like what yeah
that's interesting that's art i mean
they say often i've heard that people
when they think back they remember how
you made them feel they don't
necessarily remember what you said
exactly yeah there's another george
carlin a bit where he talks about the
changing of language he says he's he
said we used to we used to say
that when people go to war they would
come back with wait i think i remember
this i think i've seen this one and then
he's like now we say post-traumatic
stress disorder
and that's interesting because
the the way you say something could be
offensive to someone regardless of the
idea you're trying to convey
for sure it also depends upon that
person's state of mind which is why it's
complicated to put to put all the onus
on the person who is presumably giving
offense it could be that a person
is actually
empty inside
and so because they're empty inside they
will take everything to a fence because
they have low self-esteem i think we see
that very uh prominently among the
woke
the the establishment left they're i
think they're very insecure okay and
that's why they tend to be more
collectivist and that's why they tend to
be more more like do you think more
insecure people are collectivists what's
the relationship between collectivism
and insecurity finding validation from
someone else instead of themselves well
but let me ask you this question don't
you think there's a hyper
individualistic problem within america
and or do you think that
so i'm trying to see what the balance is
between
like hyper atomization of the individual
and
uh collectivism so i would say um
they're they're they're probably i think
there is a problem with individuals in
the united states yeah and it and it it
forms itself in that nobody's willing to
stand up for a common set of values
they're like look i can't lose my job
i'm not going to speak up
and that results in you know kind of
chaos
okay if you if you have
you know an element of what we refer to
as the left in the culture war that are
absolutely willing to just say whatever
the tribe says even if the you know
the change of the wind or whatever like
one day they're making fun of asian
people the next said stop asian hate
yeah yeah and they started cancelling
their own activists because a year ago
it was okay to hate a nation people and
call them white adjacent right and so
for for them
their willingness to stand up and speak
up and yell no matter what because they
seek validation from others results in
them gaining territory
in institutions i guess what i'm
wondering is though uh reinhold niebuhr
has this wonderful quote in one of his
essays i forgot the name of it um
everyone should read reinhold neighbor
though yes he's awesome um where he says
man needs liberty but also a man needs
community and there will always be a
tension between those two so i'm just
wondering what where this community and
and collectivism begin for you
um collectivism in my critique is more
about
disregarding fundamental principles and
values for the sake of just fitting in
okay finding your value in someone else
because you don't find any within
yourself okay so i think
i i would say something like hey here
are the things that i believe in i
believe there's you know intrinsic
rights that human beings have no matter
what even if you try to take them away
and i think we should protect those
rights but i also recognize at a certain
point we have to have common missions
one of the big problems with the united
states is actually
the right has lost their sense of
collective in a lot of ways and the left
has lost their sense of principle
you know so now it's just like
people on the right don't protest
they've started to more so in recent
times but it's still typically the same
groups and not the average person who
finds themselves on the right as it were
okay the left protests for anything even
if it makes no sense like when antifa
comes out and says we're against fascism
but then actually beats people in
defense of state mandates which is like
what sure because they'll come out for
anything yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you